i
[Música]
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález francia fue
a las urnas para la primera ronda de las
elecciones presidenciales un primer paso
para determinar quién será el nuevo
residente del palacio del elíseo o si se
mantiene allí el actual presidente
manuel marco del partido la república en
marcha quien aspira a la reelección en
esta primera ronda el mandatario lideró
con el 27% de los votos seguido por
marine lepén de reagrupación nacional
quien obtuvo el 23 por ciento el próximo
24 de abril será realizada entonces la
segunda vuelta definitiva una fecha
crucial para la política francesa para
la política europea y así es como se
está organizando el panorama veamos
terminado la primera vuelta de las
elecciones francesas ya se conocen las
predicciones sobre las próximas
intenciones de los votantes franceses
54% de los encuestados por la empresa de
sondeos ipsos afirma que tiene intención
de votar en manuel bacón en la segunda
vuelta miras que 46% tiene previsto
respaldar a marín depp en un resultado
que estaría mucho más ajustado que en
2017 cuando la actual presidente se
impuso a la líder ultraderechista con el
66% de los votos y juró su primer
mandato durante las próximas dos semanas
mahoney lepén harán todo lo posible para
convencer a los ciudadanos franceses de
que les voten pero para una gran parte
de los electores que piensan sufragar
esa elección ya está hecha los
candidatos de todo el espectro político
han pedido a sus seguidores que apoyen
al presidente mientras que el recién
llegado a la extrema derecha a eriksen
un apoyo al epp en el líder izquierdista
y alumno lección llamó esta vez a
bloquear a la otra derecha después de
negarse a aconsejar a sus votantes en
2017 un llamamiento que podría tener un
grave efecto en los resultados después
de que menciona eran más de una quinta
parte de los votos pero animar a la
gente a acudir a las urnas también será
una de las prioridades de los candidatos
en la primera vuelta se estima que un 26
por ciento de los votantes se negó a
votar un aumento de lo que ya había sido
una alta tasa de abstención en 2017
ese fue el resumen de la jornada así es
como está el escenario político en
francia tal parece que esto es como un
déjà vú nuevamente el ejecutivo francés
entonces será disputado entre un liberal
económico ferviente defensor de la unión
europea y una política euroescéptica un
poco más del lado de la anti inmigración
que busca reforzar e impulsar los
llamados valores franceses y esos
conceptos que han sostenido a la
república francesa los retos del nuevo
presidente o presidenta son múltiples
veamos cuáles son
el poder adquisitivo fue el tema
principal de la campaña presidencial
aunque en el último semestre de 2021
hubo una disminución general del
desempleo sigue siendo uno de los
desafíos más importantes ya que cerca
del 16 por ciento de los jóvenes seguía
sin empleo a finales del 2021 los
franceses también piden mejores salarios
y empleos menos precarios
vivir con 1.300 euros parecía imposible
tenemos un salario neto mínimo de 1800
euros porque nos parece el mínimo
realmente necesario para poder pagar
nuestro el medio ambiente es otra de las
grandes preocupaciones se demostró otra
vez en una protesta en parís este sábado
seguimos diciendo que este mandato de
cinco años es la última oportunidad de
materia ecológica y climática el ipc se
ha publicado un informe que nos dice una
vez más lo mucho que se está acelerando
esta crisis y que tenemos que tomar
medidas más rápidas para combatir el
cambio climático en 2021 el estado
francés fue condenado por el tribunal
administrativo de parís por su falta de
acción sobre la crisis climática
finalmente la guerra en ucrania se
convirtió en un tema central en el país
se espera que francia que tiene la
presidencia del consejo de la unión
europea siga intentando mediar en el
conflicto y denunciando las atrocidades
que se cometen en
los medios de presión son seguir estando
presentes ante la opinión pública
francesa recordar que la guerra continúa
recordar que las atrocidades continúan
los crímenes de guerra continúan las
autoridades rusas deben saber que el
apoyo no se debilita a pesar del
cansancio los iones a la fecha los
franceses han demostrado que están
especialmente abiertos a recibir
refugiados ucranianos y el estado tiene
el reto de responder por su atención
integral sin embargo la inmigración en
general y el manejo de la seguridad han
sido temas sensibles de esta compañía la
población francesa está muy dividida
sobre la cuestión de la inmigración y
una mayoría de franceses se dice
preocupada por el tema además el estado
tiene el desafío constante de gestionar
flujos migratorios a sus fronteras
distintos a los ucranianos la lucha
contra la inseguridad y el aumento de
los efectivos policiales fue un tema
clave para todos los candidatos si el
sentimiento de inseguridad sigue estable
con un 20 por ciento de franceses que
declara no sentirse en seguridad sobre
todo son las denuncias por las
violencias sexuales y de género que
explotaron en los últimos años pero sólo
en el debate de france 24 analizamos el
panorama político francés después de
esta primera ronda de las elecciones
presidenciales y vemos cómo queda el
escenario de cara a esa segunda vuelta
que es definitiva para determinar
entonces quién será el nuevo líneas del
palacio del elíseo para analizar este
tema hemos invitado a pilar martínez va
a ser ella es licenciada en historia
contemporánea y doctora en ciencias
políticas por la universidad de parís 1
ella se encuentra en la ciudad de nantes
en francia y en la ciudad de madrid en
españa según esta conversación
oma guillemin él es politólogo y también
consultor en asuntos públicos ustedes
también los televidentes pueden
participar en este debate con los
comentarios y las preguntas que deseen
hacer lo pueden hacer a través de las
redes sociales no se encuentran en
facebook también en instagram en twitter
les recuerdo estamos como france24 guión
bajo esa rúa santi logo que es mi cuenta
personal nuestro numeral el debate efe
24 es indispensable para que dejen todos
los comentarios allí para hacerle
seguimiento a los comentarios a las
preguntas que ustedes hacen en torno a
este tema comienzo entonces con pilar en
la ciudad de nantes en francia
comenzando por la pregunta básica pilar
su opinión sobre esta jornada el
panorama general de lo que vimos ayer en
francia en un resultado prácticamente
esperado un resultado cantado pero
también subió la apatía por parte de los
franceses a participar en estos comicios
su balance general como punto de partida
bueno mi balance general como
observadora y votante y además con esa
doble nacionalidad es
hispano-francesa bueno yo en primer
lugar me sorprendió la presencia en los
colegios electorales de numerosos
votantes cosa que no vi en las
elecciones anteriores a la diputación a
las elecciones europeas hasta que eso ya
para mí fue un siendo importante a pesar
de la tasa de abstención que se ha visto
en el conjunto del país eso ya
importante y luego también yo creo que
los resultados no estaban tan cantados
como hoy a todo lo pasado como se dice
en españa se puede decir porque yo diría
que a semejanza en mi caso había muchos
electores
cercanos a la izquierda pero una
izquierda muy plural muy atomizada en
este momento que la víspera de las
elecciones en reuniones
y formales académicas no teníamos
todavía claro por quién íbamos a votar
dentro de los candidatos de izquierdas o
sea que el tercer candidato melón show
estuvo hasta un cierto momento con una
cierta posibilidad de poder llegar al
segundo a la segunda posición a qué se
refería y ese sería mi primer comentario
perfecto pilar paso ahora hacerle la
misma pregunta a joma en la ciudad de
madrid en la capital española su balance
de esta jornada electoral francesa qué
sensación le dejó su perspectiva
las tardes a todos pues efectivamente
estoy estoy de acuerdo con lo que
comentó pilar no no estaba tan cantado
es el resultado y finalmente aunque las
dinámicas habían sido enmarcadas por
parte de los profesionales de encuestas
estas últimas semanas vimos una unas
subidas bastante sorpresa y fuerte por
parte de mi nación que llegó a 420 mil
votos de quedar como de segundo y pasar
a la segunda vuelta que hubiese sido sin
sin lugar a dudas una gran sorpresa y un
panorama que nadie había realmente he
esperado por lo cual no no estaba
encantado efectivamente tenemos esta
esta partida de vuelta del 2017 en
durante meses
se había comentado que los franceses no
quería ver ese duelo de nuevo entre
macro ni lepén y al final es lo que ha
pasado por lo cual yo entiendo la
pregunta y el comentario sin embargo hay
diferencias son dos candidatos que
llegan diferentes los perfiles
diferentes a los de 2017 en macro en
2017 estaba poco conocido una recién
entrante en la política francesa ahora
es un presidente que tiene un balance
por defender y marín depende
efectivamente ha pasado cinco años en la
oposición y tiene como una una posición
más asentada más fuerte entonces sería
seria esto un poco
punto de vista grande estas mos
buen punto de partida para esta debate
varios puntos para analizar muchas
aristas quiero comenzar entonces con la
participación antes de hablar de el
rompecabezas cómo se arma para la
segunda vuelta quiero que hablemos de
los puntos llamativos de lo que sucedió
en los comicios primero la participación
hay cierta apatía por lo por parte de
los franceses
en torno a estas elecciones
presidenciales una abstención que llegó
al 26% joma
como es el votante actual francés
quienes son los que están votando y cuál
es el sentimiento generalizado porque
tanta apatía o por lo menos eso lo que
uno siente desde la distancia
bueno tanta apatía efectivamente estamos
cuatro puntos por encima de la
participación de los últimos comicios
presidenciales en francia en la elección
presidencial siempre ha sido la
dirección reina por decirlo así que
movilizaba mucho a los votantes por lo
cual es verdad que 26% es alto pero no
fue la el resultado de abstención más
alto en 2002 por ejemplo estábamos en un
28 por ciento por lo cual
no sé si podríamos hablar de apatía
tampoco vamos a ver si el resultado de
la primera vuelta va a dar ganas a los
más de 12 mil 12 millones perdón de
abstencionistas de movilizarse sin lugar
a dudas es una de las claves para los
resultados de la segunda montana esto
y por supuesto el electorado de
dimensión que llega de tercero y que va
a ser absolutamente clave para poder
analizar un poco lo que lo que podría
pasar el ar.drone 1510 punto importante
que vamos a analizar en unos minutos
goma pilar su opinión sobre estas
votaciones sobre la participación el
electorado francés en general es un
electorado más joven que influencia
tienen las minorías los migrantes que ya
son nacionalizados franceses su caso por
ejemplo ustedes españolas ya es
nacionalizada francesa y ha tenido la
oportunidad de participar en estos
comicios y su perspectiva
bueno yo diría así a nivel general que
es cierto que como en otros países esta
abstención
creo que es la respuesta a la idea de
que está muy generalizada yo creo en el
mundo de que la política en general ya
no tiene el poder de cambiar la vida y
eso yo creo que hay que integrarlo en
ese sentido de que muchos electores de
muchas generaciones no únicamente en los
jóvenes considera que de todas maneras
su voto no va a cambiar nada en la vida
de un país pero hay algo que es
interesante de observar estamos justo al
día siguiente o sea que yo he seguido un
poco pues todo lo que la prensa francesa
de todo tipo de ideología escrito y
por internet etcétera entonces es
interesante por ejemplo ver que en los
barrios de la región parisina del área
en torno a la ciudad las conurbaciones
en estos barrios de emigrantes de varias
generaciones en que la población no
votaba en general ha gustado mucho más
habría que ir verdaderamente un
escrutinio
ciudad por ciudad y pequeña ciudad por
pequeña ciudad han votado mucho más y
ese voto en general ha ido a melón sur
entonces yo creo que esto es un éxito
interesante de lo que podría ser esta
izquierda o esta nueva izquierda de
menor son que ha mostrado mucho el país
con un discurso que a lo mejor ha
llegado más que en otros en otros
lugares y yo creo que el electorado
francés y en mi caso claro ellos es
verdad que tengo una posición que no es
la del emigrante económico o la del
exiliado político de generaciones
anteriores yo fue una migración de tipo
académico digamos y luego pues me he
quedado aquí y trabajo entre los dos
países entonces yo lo que he observado
es más bien el electorado que no está
integrado en francia o que evidentemente
en ciertos lugares tiene actitudes
comunitarias y evidentemente considera
que ese voto
a cambiar no lo va a integrar más a
placer de estos templos quedado entonces
es verdad que lo que sí ha habido en ese
electorado ha sido un choque brutal ante
los discursos de eriksen wood que ha
sido el nuevo político que ha llegado
sin ningún tipo de experiencia en la
vida política porque la polemista y esos
discursos en partido reconquista estos
sí que han producción rural en ciertas
minorías
pilar continuó con usted
veo que los dos han tocado el tema de
jean-luc mélenchon que es el candidato
que pues prácticamente le pisó los
talones a marín le pen quedó a 0 8 % de
igualar a la líder de la llamada extrema
derecha y en francia
lo han destacado como un punto
importante de cara a la segunda vuelta
que se puede decir de el desempeño de
esta izquierda una izquierda que está
muy fracturada y en francia pero él
logró aglutinar digamos que la gran
mayoría segundo pues este resultado que
se puede decir pilar cuál es el balance
que usted hace este candidato y qué
puede esperar de sus votantes para la
siguiente vuelta
pues yo creo que una cosa es el
candidato porque es verdad que es un
candidato que hablaba más al lo que él
decía en la unión popular o al pueblo
más que a francia es decir tuvo un
principio de campaña que se parecía en
francia y una expresión que dice
compararnos razonar con padres donde
padres o en tendría en algunos momentos
de su campaña un discurso que podría
aproximarse a él allende de chile es
decir es alguien que está muy próximo
américa latina y que ha vivido en esa
generación de esas revoluciones de
izquierda en américa latina' entonces en
un primer momento de campaña es verdad
que tenía una cierta posición bastante
radical en muchos puntos sobre todo
política internacional y eso en un
principio las restó votantes y sin
embargo lo que sí es importante es que
menos son frente a otros candidatos
de cualquier ideología política es un
excelente orador o sea tiene un
conocimiento y una cultura nacional
internacional y literaria una oratoria
que evidentemente no tiene nada que ver
con los discursos de marcón que son
mucho más formados ni la versión más
pasados por unas escuelas francesas el
orador melón son se parece más a los
grandes tributos y américa latina que el
formato francés o europeo yo creo que lo
que sí hay llegado en sus discursos
porque yo sólo he visto entre el
alumnado de la universidad al llegado
ese discurso muchos los jóvenes porque
hablaba de temas que les concernía
directamente o sea al garros eso el
poder adquisitivo de las condiciones en
la universidad de la educación de la
vida de todos los días ya que yo creo
que esas dos esas dos caras de melón son
han impedido que llegar a la segunda
vuelta con holgura
han propiciado que muchos jóvenes que no
hubieran votado esta vez hayan votado
por el claro toma su opinión sobre este
candidato que quedó en esta tercera
posición y estuvo a punto de pasar a
esta segunda vuelta operación panorama
muy interesante que estaríamos
analizando de haber sido así
sí bueno primero coincido completamente
con pilar que es un morador de excepción
que tiene tiene una carisma que ha
captado mucho la atención es verdad que
se ha terminado de instalar como la
figura de la izquierda en francia
la situación ha cambiado completamente
en 10 años no estaba lejos detrás de
fonz o donde en 2012 y ahora deja un
partido socialista totalmente destrozado
y si es verdad que hemos visto una
subida de intenciones de voto a lo largo
de las últimas semanas tenía ya una base
sólida de seguidores de gente que
verdaderamente estaban con un voto de
aprobación y también es cierto que en
los últimos días
se se ha anotado una voluntad o una
decisión un poco de último medio minuto
por lo que se denomina un poco en
francés como el voto útil no él
destacaba como el candidato más fuerte
la voz más alta de la izquierda y
entonces mucha gente ha querido también
darle su chance para que posiblemente la
izquierda francesa tenga una voz en la
segunda vuelta
indudablemente queda queda él en una
situación de arbitraje muy fuerte él ha
dado algunas consignas al respecto de
manera
clara pero no directa
y es cierto que yo creo que ahora mismo
en estas 15 en estos 15 días para
intentar influir en el programa del
presidente macro para que él pueda
contar por parte de
su de su apoyo que va a ser difícil
porque según las encuestas si bien en
2017 un poco más del 50 por ciento del
electorado tenía la intención de votar
para el manual ma con esa cifra ahora
gira en torno a los 30 por ciento por lo
cual ser su electorado es el electorado
clave junto con las abstencionistas que
hay de la fractura de la izquierda
francesa de este estos partidos
progresistas franceses y este electorado
que presentan estas divisiones que le ha
costado a la izquierda consolidarse este
paso dado por este candidato y este
resultado obtenido puede servir para
cicatrizar un poco la izquierda francesa
como lo que usted de goma
es muy complejo
las ruinas lo que queda del partido
socialista se tiene que se tiene que
reinventar completamente y partir de
cero entonces ahí yo creo que lo que me
lanzó ha hecho que no ha hecho el
partido socialista es pensar de nuevo un
proyecto para el país tener un nuevo
discurso nuevas ideas y es verdad que lo
que solía denominarse como la
socialdemocracia en francia ya casi ya
casi no existe entonces ahí es ese polo
de atracción va a ser alrededor de menos
son aunque ya no va a ser menos o si lo
tenemos si lo tenemos entendido
correctamente es decir que era su última
campaña después de esto él va a liderar
las elecciones legislativas del mes de
junio y normalmente va a dejar
la nueva generación del partido tomar
como el liderazgo pero es verdad que en
la configuración que vemos en estos
resultados la fuerza de su partido va a
ser un poco del pueblo de atracción
alrededor del mejor o si podría
recomponer algo eso va hacia mi
siguiente pregunta ya vamos poco más de
medio programa tengo que avanzar con
otros temas y hablemos ya de cara a la
segunda vuelta cómo se van a
reconfigurar entonces esas fuerzas
políticas varios candidatos que no
pasaron y que tuvieron votaciones
menores del umbral exigido ya dijeron
que le daban su respaldo o al pp o al
presidente marco la mayoría de ellos van
con el presidente marco pilar su
perspectiva para esta segunda vuelta
como se reconfiguran estas fuerzas
políticas
es complicado porque es verdad que es un
reto terrible
intenta proyectarse de aquí en 15 días
porque es verdad que hay una primera
tentación pero veo que como el programa
tal como lo propone habéis profundizado
mucho en lo que es este periodo
electoral o sea que no cabe y las
generalidades yo creo que sería muy
bueno decir que bueno se va a reproducir
lo que se produjo hace cinco años y que
mack contiene verdaderamente un camino
totalmente directo para llegar al elíseo
yo no estoy tan segura de que sea tan
fácil para macon en el contexto actual
pensar en una victoria sin ningún tipo
de contratistas porque lo que va a haber
bastante
independientemente de los consideras de
los partidos yo creo que hay un
electorado que no está encartado en tal
o cual partido es un electorado que yo
diría bola aquí y aunque estos partidos
la izquierda el partido comunista que ha
hecho pues evidentemente se presentaba
en este contexto ha hecho pues su
funcionalidad realmente bajo y tan yo
pienso que por mucha consigna que estos
partidos del de votar amac como para
hacer un frente frente a la extrema
derecha no estoy segura que los
electores sigan todas las consignas
porque lo que sí hay es un yo diría un
frente anti macu porque los resultados
de estos cinco años no han sido tan
positivos como pueden parecer en el
extranjero yo mis amigos analistas que
viven y la españa de eso me dicen
comprendes me di claro no es que este
excelente presidente
los logros que ha tenido cuando se está
dentro del país se ve y también es un
país en blanco y negro con muchos tintes
género y la mucha población que se ha
dejado fuera se extiende mucho con las
respuestas y tengo muchas cosas para
preguntarle quiero conocer su análisis
de muchos temas desde mac al programa
tomar rápidamente su perspectiva para
esta para esta segunda vuelta de la
configuración de las fuerzas y que
podemos ver en estas dos semanas por
parte de los candidatos a qué temas
fuertes podemos ver que se puedan
concentrar en estas dos semanas que les
queda para tratar de convencer más
votantes
encuestas inmediatas del macro ganador a
55 frente a 45 es verdad que él tiene
más reservas posibles de voto por lo
cual es la gran probabilidad pero muchas
cosas pueden pasar el debate de
televisado en francia suele ser un punto
de inflexión muy importante también y
como bien sabéis en 2017 ha sido ha sido
un marcador fuerte de la campaña en el
cual el epen ha salido bastante
malparada
realmente por lo cual esto podría ser
también un punto de inflexión para macro
el ejercicio es bastante sencillo es
tratar de atraer al electorado de la
izquierda sin espantar a su base
electoral de derecha entonces va a tener
que hacer malabares y ampliar un poco la
frente ayer ha dicho estoy dispuesto a
inventar algo nuevo que sea algo nuevo
hoy en su en sus visitas de terreno
algunas señales de que podría abrir un
poco su programa a temas de poder
adquisitivo al tema de medio ambiente y
al tema de más vertiente más social
entonces vamos a ver en los días que
vienen su verdadera voluntad de incluir
a otros temáticas a otras temáticas de
respecto al político entonces en este
sentido esto esto va a ser por por su
parte el gran desafío y deben mantener
su imagen de mujer de estado capaz de
gobernar porque es lo que le hizo falta
en 2017 y su ejercicio sin lugar a dudas
va a ser más difícil que para el
presidente macrón pero otra vez
cualquier cosa puede pasar en el camino
o más sigo con usted rápidamente para
hacerle la misma pregunta a los dos pero
comenzó para hacer la ronda a la inversa
a qué tipo de francia nos vamos a
enfrentar con uno o con el otro
candidato son dos perspectivas muy
distintas las que proponen el presidente
y aspirante a la reelección y la
candidata el epen
totalmente aquí bueno en caso de una
victoria de marine le pen seria un
cambio radical de planteamiento frente a
ante todo a la unión europea ya quiere
proponer el área orientación de los
tratados europeos y una visión
totalmente distinta a esta están los
otros países estados miembros de la
unión europa mirando esta perspectiva
con mucha preocupación entonces por ese
lado ese sería el punto más más
importante y por el lado de macrón si
bien tiene esas probabilidades más altas
de ganar en la configuración actual dado
lo que decía pilar de este frente anti
macro no es bien probable que sea
difícil para él gobernar habrá que ver
también las condiciones de las elevadas
legislativas desde junio pero estamos a
la espera de tener una tercera vuelta en
la calle como la solemos comentar en
francia hemos visto los chalecos
amarillos hemos visto los anti vacunar
estos movimientos sociales muy fuertes
de contestación
y en esas en ese análisis análisis de
resultados es muy probable que que la
francia de manuel macro
siga con esta esta vía de contestación
que está bien concienciación en la calle
y pilar' su perspectiva de estas 2
francias tan distintas que proponen los
candidatos también que estos dos
candidatos estén en la segunda vuelta
también es un síntoma de esa
polarización de la sociedad francesa se
ha profundizado se profundiza de cara a
esta segunda vuelta su análisis
si estoy realmente de acuerdo con lo que
ha propuesto como análisis omar es
exactamente eso yo creo que se podría
hablar más bien de tres pronuncias
porque el electorado de menos son está
ahí en una recomposición posible de lo
que sería una nueva izquierda pero es
cierto que él en la victoria del epen
tendría consecuencias a nivel
internacional importante luego a nivel
nacional es evidente que dentro de lo
que es el partido de letrán a pesar de
que ha sido reestructurado en estos
últimos años no tiene tampoco cuadros
suficientes para poder gobernar a todos
los niveles sobre todo es un partido que
está muy ausente de lo que es la
política regional no tienen
evidentemente dirigentes racionales no
tienen grandes ciudades tienen muy pocas
ciudades como alcaldía y yo creo que la
victoria de macro no es exactamente lo
que ha dicho omar es decir que por mucho
que hoy haya hecho una cita con sogas
pero era de un posibilismo que a nadie
se le ha escapado yo pienso que es muy
difícil que alguien como mccomb por
mucho que intente centrarse o ir un poco
hacia la izquierda es alguien que puede
posibilitar está este nuevo esto lo que
es la tercera vuelta de la calle claro
que ese descontento no va a terminarse
dentro de 15 días dentro de ser
descontento pilar que grupos de la
sociedad francesa van a ser claves la
comunidad musulmana los migrantes de
diferentes países los nuevos votantes
los jóvenes quienes van a ser cruciales
dentro del espectro de la sociedad
pues yo pienso que es difícil hacer una
segmentación por generaciones porque en
el electorado que hemos analizado hoy es
un elector también muy fragmentado
incluso los más de 60 incluso los
jóvenes etcétera es cierto que la
cuestión identitaria
seguirá siendo planteada que la cuestión
de seguridad también está muy presente
lloro que algo que seguro que con omar
si tuviéramos más tipos podríamos decir
lo más preocupante yo creo en este nuevo
en esta nueva configuración es que los
temas abordados por la extrema derecha
tanto por repente como por ser muy han
sido totalmente normalizados en la
sociedad es decir que esos temas de lo
que es evidentemente el racismo rechazo
del otro eran la gran sustitución que
eran temas que antes nunca se abordaron
los medios de comunicación y en las
conversaciones hoy se han vuelto normal
y el número de votos de las dos extremas
derechas de más del 30 por ciento del
país agotado por esa ideología es decir
claro que eso es lo que para mí
constituye el auténtico problema del
futuro en este momento
coma y desde este análisis que hace el
pilar eso nos lleva también a ver muchas
coyunturas que se están viendo en el
resto de europa la reciente elección en
hungría dice mucho quienes están
gobernando en polonia francia estaría
comenzando a ponerse en sintonía con ese
sentimiento que hay en europa de extrema
derecha cuál cuál es su análisis
son son situaciones
totalmente distintas y hay que tomarlo
con mucho matiz no pero es verdad que
vemos desde desde hace algunos años una
tendencia a irse más hacia la derecha en
europa es verdad eso es cierto no se
puede negar los los países que siguen en
el ámbito de la socialdemocracia en
europa son españa portugal algunos
países del norte de europa pero pero
pero es cierto que hay por ese lado
vamos
tampoco podría de manera contundente
decir que esta tendencia marcada
corresponde o tiene las mismas
explicaciones y causas que lo que ha
pasado en hungría por ejemplo que sigue
pasando pero pero en esto estamos y es
bien cierto que señalando las categorías
como como hacías la pregunta a pilar yo
yo diría que son los jóvenes que van a
ser clave - o han llegado lejos y de
primero en estas categorías de 18 o 24
años y de 25 a 34 por lo cual yo creo
que aquí
clave es este es el voto de los jóvenes
y la manera con la cual van a ver y
percibir
esa segunda vuelta y esa alternativa
pues ya veremos qué va a pasar el
próximo 24 de abril fecha clave que se
definirá entonces el destino político de
francia si continúa en manuel mayo al
frente de este país europeo país
importante a nivel económico para el
bloque de los 27 sobre todo con la
coyuntura en la que están en este
momento con el conflicto en ucrania y la
dependencia energética que tienen varios
países de rusia que también ha sentado
ya un presidente a lo largo de estos
meses con la crisis con ucrania ya
veremos quién va a ser el entonces el
residente del eligió a pilar y ajo más
les agradezco mucho por su análisis y
ustedes muchas gracias por la sintonía
por haber estado con nosotros sigan con
france24
[Música]